oh hello everybody it is very nice to be
here
I do love this city I must say because
like no matter what night of the week it
is all the bars around here always break
out some big drink special you know what
most of them are okay they're like
bucket of beers or ladies drink free but
like sometimes I'll hear about a drink
special that sounds like borderline
dangerous like my friend will call me up
and be like man we gotta go to Oh
Halligan's tonight it is nickel shot
night I'm pretty sure we'll die if we go
to Oh Halligan's nickel shot night
should be illegal this time of year is
very cool cuz this is when all the big
summer action movies come out you know
these big blockbusters you'll read about
them in the paper and you'll hear that
they cost something like 100 million
dollars whenever I hear that I always
think like you didn't need to make a
movie with that money I would have
bought a ticket just to see 100 million
dollars like I'm at a point in my life
where I would wait online to look at
that much cash you could just like stack
it up in a motel room line us up down
the hall have some guy out front like
it's eight dollars to see the hundred
million or ten dollars to have your
money added to the hundred million cool
very luxurious would it be fun think
about it you'd go into this room and
there would be like stacks of hundred
dollar bills and jewelry and like gold
coins spilling out of a pirate chest cuz
pirates never bring a big enough chest
in pictures the gold coins are always
overflowing it why is that I think that
maybe with the eye patches they have
poor depth perception okay one guy with
a lot of money that fascinates me is
Donald Trump he is a he is a rich man
he's a very much actually no to me
Donald Trump is not just a rich man
Donald Trump is like what a hobo
imagines a rich man to be like Donald
Trump was walking through an alley and
he heard some guy just like as soon as
my number comes in I'm gonna put up tall
buildings with my name on him
I'll have fine golden hair and a TV show
where I fire people with my children and
Trump is like that is how I will live my
life Thank You hobo for that life plan
I thought when Donald Trump makes a
decision he thinks to himself what would
a cartoon rich person do he puts his
name on everything like that's gonna
stop him from dying right did he see
Citizen Kane but not the end he paused
it at 89 minutes it was just like this
is a very happy ending
he's one of the finest DVDs in Manhattan
he will be my guest at the watching of
this DVD
I don't watch his show that often I only
have one favorite show and that is Law &
Order that is my absolute favorite song
yes I talk about order a lot okay
because I'm obsessed with it like I
watched so much Law & Order that
sometimes I think I'm on an episode of
Law & Order like I'll be walking to the
car with my friend and I'll be like hey
man you see the game last night yeah
that ref should get his eyes checked
wait a second parking garage in the
afternoon vague and crappy dialogue
we're about to find a dead body yeah
we never do great because they always
have the same recurring people on it
these same characters you see different
actors same idiots again and again some
of my personal favorite recurring
characters there is uh there's judge who
allows everything I'll allow it but
watch yourself McCoy and of course New
York City bartender who recognizes
everybody who's ever been in the bar
ever they give this guy a photo and he's
like Oh first they always make this face
like ah like their face needs to adjust
to a photograph they're like oh a
picture not for nothing but for a second
I thought it was a tiny person
[Applause]
yeah blue shirt lady nice lady came in
here Friday around 7:30 like did she
seem upset nah she was smiling guys she
was wit didn't look too happy though he
left about 935 936 it's like which New
York City do you work in
I live with people I don't recognize
when they ask the same thing every time
they're like why did something happen to
her like yeah something most definitely
did that's why the murder police are
here with a photograph of her talking
about her in the past tense thank you
very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]